hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in the second part of her work the
ethics of ambiguity simonda bouvoir is
going to run
through a sequence of different we could
call them
existential stances or modes of
existence each of which
in a certain way is defective or
deficient it betrays
human freedom by using human freedom
against itself and the first one that
she
examines is sort of like at the bottom
level
she calls it the sub man we should just
expand it to the sub
human because there's nothing
particularly gendered
about it and when when you hear that
term
it's natural to immediately associate
that with a kind of
judgmental attitude towards others that
would say that some people
are less than human on the basis of
one characteristic or another for
example
race you know some people have said
certain races
are sub-human and other races are fully
human
and this goes all the way back in the
western tradition to
you know some views of greeks and
barbarians
she has nothing like that in mind and so
you know if that's what you're
immediately going to dispel
that right away because anybody
anybody of any group could in fact fall
into this category
of the subhuman it has to do with a
person's stance
and as a matter of fact as she points
out
the people who are in this respect
subhuman
become very useful tools of racist
violence as well as other types of
violence
as well it could be motivated against
religions or you know
could be motivated against classes so
it could be tied in really with with any
sort of
violent project that would stand in the
way of human freedom so
let's talk about what she means at first
and let's begin at the beginning of the
section
she says that if we were try going to
try to establish a hierarchy among
people we would put those who are
denuded of this
living warmth and then she references
the stupidity
of which the gospel speaks and what is
that being lukewarm right
those who are spit out of the mouth
because they are neither cold nor hot
but merely lukewarm she would say this
is the lowest rung
of the ladder this is that's why they're
the sub-human they are beneath
the other modes of being a human
and she talks about that as those who
restrain the
original movement of existence what does
that mean well
as she's said a little bit earlier to
exist is to make oneself a lack of being
it is to cast oneself into the world now
if you're only reading this section you
might say well
what does that mean to exist not for
anything but to exist for a human being
is this there's two sides to this it is
to be cast into the world this is a
you know standard existentialist way of
looking at things
we are in the world before we choose to
be in the world we are in situations
and the other thing she says it's to
make oneself a lack of being
this jean paul sartre and heidegger and
others all the way back to you could say
kierkegaard have identified
as central to human existence
that we are by being what we
are not there's a central you could call
a dislocation
within our being that can never be
entirely overcome
and that is what allows us to take
stances on things even to be able to
identify
something as a lack of being requires
that in a certain sense we lack being
within ourselves and that's the mode of
our being that is what allows us
freedom as human beings so the people
who
are rejecting this she says they have
eyes and ears but from their childhood
on they make themselves blind and deaf
without love and without desire and so
one of the ways in which she talks about
this is as
apathy apathy is a lack
of passion a lack of affectivity
or it can also be a suppression of it
when it's not you know genuine apathy
sort of coming from somebody's
temperament but it's it's rather a
result perhaps of trauma
or in this case of of what the person is
doing to themself
indifference is another way of talking
about it here
and she she she goes on and she says
this apathy
manifests a fundamental fear so there is
still
some sort of aff activity a fundamental
fear
in the face of existence so
it's not a total lack of emotion but you
could say
that this fear is one that's not
allowing itself to be
felt as distinct fear
it's also not not manifesting itself as
what we typically call existentialist
anxiety
it's something a bit different the other
mode of affectivity that she brings up a
little bit later for this this person
is boredom and i think that's
particularly telling as well
boredom or tedium fear on some
some basic level of existence
ruling out the other emotions making
them
muted making them repressed
and a little bit later she says this
person discovers around him only an
insignificant and dull world how can
this naked world arouse within them any
desire to feel
to understand to live the less he exists
the less there is reason for him to
exist since these reasons are created
only by
existing so she doesn't use the term but
we could talk about this person
in contemporary terms as being
disengaged
the world that they are presented with
is a
flattened world a world that doesn't
present itself with the same
possibilities and attractiveness it's
all just kind of a humdrum
we could say a gray world right gray on
on gray and so there's this this
uh rejection of passion a rejection of
affective
involvement love or desire why is that
well it comes from this fear she says
the sub person rejects this passion
which is his human condition the
laceration and the failure of that drive
towards being which always misses its
goal
but which thereby is the very existence
which
they reject and she says that you know
this this reinforces
itself if you think that you've got a
dull world in which nothing really
important happens and people are all you
know
just kind of schmucks well then you
don't invest yourself
in that world in making choices and
actions and commitments and you get back
what you put in
and so there are many people who do in
fact live this way
now she points out and this is the case
for all of the
different um modes of of
being that she's discussing in this this
second part
it's still a use of human freedom it is
still
a human comportment this is not being a
robot
this is acting like a robot this is
reducing oneself
to the the level of the below the human
so this is still though a use of human
freedom and choice and there's
also a transcendence she says
if a person were permitted to be a brute
fact they would merge with the trees and
pebbles which are not aware they
that they exist we would consider these
opaque lives with indifference but the
sub-person invokes contempt
contempt for what because they are not
making
of their humanity what they could be one
recognizes him to be responsible
for himself at the moment that one
accuses him of not
willing himself and so she goes on and
she says another thing that's really
important here
nobody is a datum which has passively
suffered the rejection of existence is
still
another way of existing
so it involves a choice on some level
the person is responsible for themselves
and they are also responsible for
their world a world denuded of
meaning a world in which it doesn't
really matter
what they do and you know
she goes on and she says there we have
the defeat of the sub-person
he would like to forgive himself to be
ignorant of himself but the nothingness
which is at the heart of
the person is also the consciousness
they have of themselves
this negativity is revealed positively
as anguish desire
appeal laceration but as for the genuine
return to the positive the sub
person eludes it they're afraid of
engaging themselves
in a project as they're afraid of being
disengaged
and thereby of being in a state of
danger before their future
in the midst of its possibilities and so
because of this she says
they they choose to take
refuge in ready-made values
in in values that are just being
supplied from someone else it could be
the culture it could be a political
party or platform it could be an
ideology
it could be a religion it could be
whatever you like and so they take
refuge in these values they don't do it
in the way that the
next group type of person that she's
going to talk about
the serious person does so there's a bit
more of a
adventitiousness to this it could be
anything right but it allows them to
have cliches that they they use to
express
themselves and this is where we get to
another really interesting
point she calls the sub person not a
harmless creature
why because they
can be drawn into just about anything
and you might say well that's
that's kind of weird i mean you just
said they don't care about anything
they're not involved with with the world
well the the access
to values through the ready-made values
allows them to be easily
brought under any sort of cause could be
a good cause could be a bad cause
if it's a good cause they're not really
going to be endorsing it as a good cause
although they may see it as good for
themselves and if it's a bad cause
they are the ones who can be the the bad
cause enactors you might say so she goes
on and she says
they realize themselves in the world as
a blind
uncontrolled force which anyone can get
control of
lynchings in pogroms and all the great
bloody movements
organized by the fanaticism of serious
and passion
movements where there is no risk those
who do the actual dirty work are
recruited from
among the submit and she says this is
why
uh a person who wills themselves free
within a human world fashioned by free
people will be so disgusted
by some people these are the people who
do the hanging these are the people
who engage in the harassment these are
the people who make themselves
effectively bots on twitter repeating
things
you know for their their particular
cause without caring
really about what they're they're
engaged in
they've just found a purpose a home you
could say
and they think nothing of what they're
doing in terms of other people and she
says
that what they're doing is they're
opposing
inert resistance to projects of other
people so not being willing to
accept that other people have freedom
and being essentially the stop
that you will not go any further or will
club you
or burn you or uh do other things so she
says
no project has meaning in the world
disclosed by such an existence
a person is defined as a wild flight the
world about them is bare and incoherent
nothing ever happens nothing merits
desire or effort
they make their way across a world
deprived of meaning towards a death
which merely confirms
their long negation of themselves
and you know she goes on and talks about
boredom at this point they experience
the desert of the world
in their boredom and now is she going a
little bit too far with this is
by by talking about the you might say
affect uh causelessness
of this this person doesn't that deny
what she just said about they can be
used as essentially a tool for causes
no i think what we have to see here is
an ideal type and people
oscillate between these these
different polarities the sub person can
have a world that is you know mo
momentarily connected with interest
and interest in some sort of simplistic
uh
you know i'm on the good side the other
people are are the baddies
you know and it could be that they're
they're in favor of order it could be
that they're
you know doing creative chaos it could
be whatever you want
but they're not really committed to it
they're
they're just doing it to have something
to do
sometimes we say oh i did that so i
could i could feel like i was alive
again right
i think the sub man or the sub human
that she's describing
that's that's a possibility for them and
and you know it it would be driven
though
by this fear by this refusal of
existence that she takes to be central
for this type
you